luego cambio de gabinete night y tras
cuatro meses de intensas negociaciones
con la oposición el primer ministro
ariel on wye presentó a sus ministros
el primer ministro ariel presidió esta
tarde tras la investidura de los
miembros del nuevo gabinete ministerial
su primer consejo de ministros donde se
transmitieron claras instrucciones a los
titulares de los distintos ministerios
el nombramiento se da dos meses después
de que firmaron acuerdo con la oposición
que en su momento pedía la renuncia del
presidente joven el mois y lo que llevó
al primer ministro a modificar la
composición del gobierno en el
compromiso también se estipula un año
para redactar la nueva constitución y
convocar a elecciones generales
resalta del nuevo gabinete la presencia
de varias figuras de la oposición y el
retiro de clubs rousseff quien se
desempeñó como presidente interino tras
el magnicidio de maurice del ministerio
de relaciones exteriores
la juramentación se da en medio de una
creciente situación de inseguridad en el
país en donde las pandillas han avanzado
en el control de varias zonas de la isla
el mes pasado uno de los grupos
secuestró a 17 misioneros
norteamericanos
es un ambicioso y complicado desafío
contener el clima de inseguridad cuando
algunos han elegido reinar en varios
rincones de nuestro territorio
ibeas fue no textual
el nuevo gabinete tiene el desafío de
otorgarle estabilidad a un país que
además de estar sumido en la inseguridad
también se enfrenta a una creciente
pobreza
luego el terremoto que sacudió la isla
en agosto